so wie du das ist dieser typische 100
200 euro fällig maximal um das ist wird
sehr dreist wenn ich etwas zu fressen
vielleicht habe man halt vor allem als
er in der so in der öffentlichkeit steht
es gibt da ein paar kopien sieht man das
auch gut aber es gibt auch kopien oder
fuhren wo man sagt wir sind dann relativ
teuer
im letzten jahr kam 83 prozent der
plagiate aus china das ist wieder mal
ein zeichen dass ich leute damit nicht
auseinandersetzen einfach irgendwas
kaufen
[Musik]
dass ich fünf uhren die wird ja meist
gefälscht
[Musik]
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
weil die schau dich je das nächste video
an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren